إنه يوم رائع آخر هنا في
وسط مدينة دبي ، بدأت آنا سبيرسن ودانش
سهيدي عرضهما للبودكاست المشفر
في عام 2021. لذا أخبرنا قليلاً
عن داو الذي وضعته يا رفاق
هذا المصطلح يشير إلى منظمة مستقلة لامركزية.
موضوع جذب الانتباه مؤخرًا في هذا
البودكاست وفي جميع أنحاء العالم ، يتم
وصفهم كمجموعة من الأشخاص الذين
يجتمعون عادةً عبر الإنترنت بهدف مشترك
ولا يفكر أي قائد مركزي في
التصفح كطريقة جديدة
لتنظيم شركة تعرف
أن الشركات التقليدية لديها
أه  إدارة المساهمين ثم
الموظفين ، الفكرة وراء داو هي
بدلاً من ذلك تمكين جميع أعضاء تلك
المنظمة من أن يكون لهم رأي
في أن اثنين من البودكاست أحبوا المفهوم
لدرجة أنهم انتقلوا من الحديث عن
daos إلى بدء منطقتهم الخاصة
ونحن
نؤمن بعقل الخلية الذي نؤمن به  أن
المجتمع الذي لديهم المصلحة
الفضلى للمنظمة في الاعتبار
يرى الناس القيمة التي يجلبها ديل على
الطاولة
كما يقولون  لقد جمعوا أكثر من
مليون ونصف المليون دولار هذا العام عندما
أطلقوا أسلوب شركتهم الفني وهي
منظمة ترعى أفراد فن nft
يمتلكون حصة في مؤسستهم من
خلال امتلاك رمز افتراضي
وهذه الرموز تقدم حقوق التصويت على
قرارات الشركة
كبديل
لخبراء الشركات التقليدية يقولون إن الداعرات توفر مزيدًا من
الشفافية والمشاركة
بين المستثمرين
، قواعد العمل واضحة بمجرد
نشر العقود الذكية على
blockchain فهي لا رجعة فيها ولا
يمكن لأي شخص تغييرها وهذا يعطي أساسًا
مستوى عالٍ من الثقة لأصحاب المصلحة للعمل
بشكل أساسي
مع  المفهوم والقيام بأعمال تجارية
بمفهوم
annas و denosh ليسا وحدهما يظهران
في جميع أنحاء العالم ،
فبعضها جمعيات خيرية تكافح ضد
تغير المناخ بينما يفتح البعض
الآخر امتيازات للوجبات السريعة ، حتى أنها
جمعت 40 مليون دولار للمزايدة على
نسخة من  يرى خبراء الدستور الأمريكيون
اهتمامًا متزايدًا
بالكشف مؤخرًا ولكن في كاليفورنيا  تنبيهًا لأن
المفهوم لا يزال بحاجة إلى وقت لينضج ،
وأعتقد أن هيئة المحلفين لا تزال خارج الخدمة ، لذا في الوقت الحالي
، هناك
حالات استخدام واضحة جدًا في التمويل الجماعي في
إدارة الأصول ، حيث لا تزال daos موجودة
بشكل جيد للغاية ،
ولكن لا تزال الأيام الأولى لهيكل الشركة الجديد هذا ،
ولكن  أنس
ودينوش لا ينتظران حول الاثنين يعتقدان أن
daos ستحدث ثورة في مجال الأعمال
ولهذا السبب
يبنون الآن وينشرون كلمة
آنا ستيوارت.